Wow
hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be my Jessica Jones trailer videos
they haven't released an official
trailer yet but as probably right around
the corner is actually going to be
premiering November 20th so like once we
get within that four-week period they're
going to start dumping all kinds of
footage I'm also totally pumped because
I'm going to be moved into my new
apartment by then too that's literally
like all I think about when I'm not
making videos but just explain what's
going on with this footage so what it
seems like they're doing is is each time
they post a new teaser it's later in the
night like we start here in the middle
of the afternoon when she's just waking
up the reason that she is up so late is
because yeah she got super drunk last
night but she's also a private
investigator that that's what her
primary trade is it's alias
investigations that's the name of her
business so you can see the camera on
the ground you see some photos that
she's taken I tried to zoom in but it's
just a little too buzzy I couldn't tell
if any of these figures were familiar
superheroes for the Marvel Universe in
the comics she actually ends up
investigating a lot of people in and
around Civil War so don't be surprised
if you hear Civil War rumblings going on
in the background here but this is going
to be largely exclusive to the netflix
universe so if she does investigate
other known superheroes like big ones
it'll probably be people like daredevil
but I don't know how much integration
it's going to have with daredevil right
away the only thing they've confirmed
like the way they said it's kind of
tricky the language they use they said
once the character debuts inside this
universe that the netflix universe
they're fair game to cross over so I'm
expecting to hear lots of references to
the devil of Hell's Kitchen that you
know the man in the suit running around
beating the crap out of people and we
have Rosario Dawson's character so she's
kind of like the direct link to
daredevil aside from references that any
of the characters might make but because
the opening teaser here has her walking
down this same alley that Daredevils
walking down in his teaser I think she's
going to be in relatively the same area
around Hell's Kitchen crushing the alarm
clock is really funny everybody went
really crazy about that it's mostly just
to tell people that don't know anything
about Jessica Jones that she has super
strength I've heard them talk about how
they've changed her powers a little bit
from the comics she's able to fly in the
comics too so I think they tuned her
down just a little bit to bring her
closer to street level just because if
she could fly and she were super strong
she'd be kind of overpowered for the
characters that they're using in the
series and we haven't seen him yet the
purple man David Tennant but they
probably adjusted his powers just a
little bit too it's not very outwardly
visible so like in the teaser here where
it gets all tripping and purple will
we'll probably see like acid trip scenes
like that where he's trying to push his
influence on her and you kind of hear
him softly in the background of these
teasers saying Jessica Jessica this is
really creepy it's gonna be a totally
badass series just like daredevil was
but what I am really really excited to
see is how many David Tennant hardcore
fans flip their [ __ ] when they see how
evil he is seriously if they go as evil
as the character is in the comics it's
going to be really bad that's actually
good question for you guys I mean this
is Netflix it's hardcore daredevil was
pretty hardcore but it wasn't super
violent how evil do you think that David
Tennant's purple man is going to be how
close do you think he's going to beat
his character in the comics the purple
man is the quintessential scum of the
earth villain just to make a doctor who
reference he's nothing like the master
even like John Sims master who was a
little bit slimy and calculating before
he just went full-blown batshit crazy if
you want really awesome dark David
Tennant he's not a villain but you
should watch broadchurch he's one of the
good guys but it's still a really dark
series and it stars Arthur Darvill who's
in legends of tomorrow the character
he's playing rip hunter is kind of like
the Doctor Who of the DC Universe so
just you know really awesome doctor who
Marvel DC things happening right now and
what about Luke Cage though we don't see
him sleeping next to her there I'm
assuming that they're going to be a
thing whenever the series picks up like
they won't meet each other for the first
time Luke Cage will totally be a part of
our series but it remains to be seen
like what his role is going to be if
he's going to be backup support or if
they're going to be beating the [ __ ] out
of people together all the time it's
gonna be really cool having more
super-powered women in the Marvel
Universe the Marvel Cinematic Universe
we have Scarlet Witch we have Daisy
Johnson on agents of shield now we have
Jessica Jones we're like we're slowly
building things out one of the big
problems that Marvel's had in the past
is that like all their super awesome
female characters or in the x-men
universe so naturally can't use any of
them I no no Scarlet Witch is kind of an
exception but that's that's a bit of a
trick case that's actually another good
question who is your favorite female
Marvel character that you think has a
shot showing up in a Marvel movie like
one that they have the IP for so it
can't be from the x-men universe there's
definitely no wrong answer to that but I
feel like we're all whispering captain
marvel they actually just named a
director for Thor 3 Ragnarok he's not
someone you may have heard of before but
I feel like we're right
around the corner from getting some
Captain Marvel announcements they'll
probably start promoting that a little
bit more after civil war comes out and
just for those that are asking the
trailer for that and the trailer for
x-men apocalypse now like the current
rumor on windows are coming is the
beginning to the middle of November but
you know any time from like late October
just be on a red alert and don't forget
next week arrow and flash come back
agents of shield is back just be sure to
subscribe to get everything I know some
of you guys are back in school so if you
feel like you've missed anything that I
post just check my videos tab every once
in a while and there are links for my
Twitter and Facebook down at the bottom
of the description also because there's
a lot of like really awesome stuff
coming next week and I'm not super hot
on heroes right now I might end up
dropping heroes on Thursday nights but
that's still pending I could change my
mind about that while you guys wait for
everything you can click here for all my
other Marvel Netflix videos i did some
daredevil punisher a little while ago
and you can click here to get ready for
arrow in the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you